i know you can't tell me much about
craven the hunter but what's it like
stepping into this
i know we're looking i'm looking for the
snipers
i'm looking for the marvel snipers that
these mob they're there they're
assassins they're like crazy but you're
stepping to the mcu and spider-man as a
villain what is that like this character
that's it
okay okay i'll give you a bit more than
that let's go there's just someone i am
really um
i'm really behind man i'm really excited
about what we can uh we can do with this
character he's really interesting he's
got a really great backstory that we're
hoping to share and it's gonna be
different man it's gonna be a little bit
different
so
what remember those two wackos from the
bolivia job the twins yeah and i'm so
sure they're twins get off the train so
you and brian tyree henry twin assassins
in this movie the mcu tentacles keep
y'all close
they keep y'all close
it's dangerous what was it like teaming
up with him on this film god it was
everything you know like i didn't know
who my character tan dream was until he
stepped into the shoes of lemon i mean
he's such a talented versatile actor i
mean i've watched so much stuff of his
and so
it was a blessing really because you
know he stepped on and then we was just
instantaneously like we connected you
know as like friends and like real feel
like a real brotherhood so like um i'm
grateful for him man you know and it was
that trust that made us just kind of
riff and kind of improv and do our thing
you know that's that little bit of magic
just he said the same thing he said
you're now his emergency contact yeah
that's right i noticed i noticed but you
know he's definitely not mine because
he's busy working thank you every time i
call him i'm like bro you gotta come
around he's like oh man he's in
australia tomorrow he's i just told him
he was in atlanta he was shooting
atlanta in london for a minute and then
he went back
i can't he just doesn't sit still i told
him i said you look up booked and busy
in the dictionary it's you it's the
picture of you okay okay second thing
aaron i have heard from several
different sources meaning your cast
mates that this cast is actually a band
and the name of the band is yeah naked
below the line
it's the thing and brian said the first
album is called no harness
yeah
with the harness is something nasty
but
the rehearsals i mean it's something you
don't want to see it's just are you the
drummer are you the bass player are you
and we're still figuring things out like
we're still experimenting but brad's the
manager and he's in the band
brad's been carrying a guitar case
around there's no guitar in it it's got
his dirty laundry in it but he carries
the guitar case everywhere we go that is
real
but we don't know how good he is yet so
we don't really know okay
okay i can do it i can do it we have
seen you guys just really bonded and it
does feel like you're a family you
really like each other that chemistry
you can't play huh
yeah we're doing a good job you're about
to go out on your own solo project and
leave the band
we have had this weird
freaking family love affair like it's
been crazy like we came and made this
movie a pandemic
like we needed each other you know we
kind of like had we just sort of like
infiltrate each other and then brian's
got this
big light joy his laughter is infectious
and we just need each other you know we
kind of came in each other's lives at
the right moment when we needed
uplifting and then we made this movie in
the dark time and we created something
that you know we won't disappoint people
gonna gonna laugh you know that's good i
love that we need to laugh
[Music]
you